un aliado cercano del presidente ruso
vladimir putin fue capturado por las
autoridades ucranianas víctor med de
chuck había estado escondido desde que
escapó del arresto domiciliario en
ucrania durante los primeros días de la
invasión rusa el servicio de seguridad
de ucrania anunció su captura en un
comunicado el martes por la noche en una
operación especial elogiada por el
presidente bola de emails el esquí
encuentro especialmente cínico de su
parte usar camuflaje militar él trató de
disfrazarse así que soldado que patriota
bueno si medved suc elige un uniforme
militar para sí mismo cae bajo las
reglas de la guerra
propongo a la federación rusa que
intercambie a este tipo suyo por
nuestros niños y niñas que ahora están
en cautiverio ruso med de chuck es un
amigo cercano de putin el presidente
ruso es el padrino de una de sus hijas
el oligarca ucraniano lideró el partido
pro kremlin plataforma de oposición por
la vida cuyo objetivo era alejar al país
de occidente el hombre de 67 años es uno
de varios políticos pro moscú acusados
de participar en un complot revelado por
eeuu para establecer un gobierno
colaborador pro kremlin antes de la
invasión rusa de ucrania desde su
sorpresiva elección en 2019 el
presidente selenski ha estado liderando
una campaña de presión contra menos de
chuck en febrero del año pasado tres
canales de televisión pro rusos que se
creía eran un de propiedad del magnate
fueron sacados del aire selenski dijo
que era un movimiento necesario en la
lucha contra la propaganda rusa
posteriormente met de hecho fue acusado
de traición culpado de vender secretos
militares a moscú y de explotar los
recursos naturales de crimea bajo la
ocupación rusa su partido político fue
suspendido rápidamente después de la
invasión moscú se ha negado a comentar
sobre su detención